and the final piece of advice I love
that picture
okay it's to look up to the stars and
appreciate every single moment you're
alive at the mystery of this world at
the the beauty of this world again this
is my perspective taking with a grain of
salt but I advise the forever oscillate
between deep profound doubt and self
dissatisfaction and the deep gratitude
for the moment for just being alive for
all the people around you they give you
their love with whom you get to share
those moments to share the love a poem
by Stephen Crane that I especially like
in the desert in the desert I saw a
creature and naked beastial who's
squatting up on the ground
held this heart in his hands and ate of
it I said is a good friend it is bitter
bitter he answered but I like it because
it is bitter and because it is my heart
so I would say the bitter is the self to
satisfaction not to think that's the
Restless energy that drives us forward
and then enjoying that bitterness and
enjoying the moment and enjoying the
sweetness that comes from eating your
own heart in this poem is is the thing
that makes life worthwhile and that is
to me happiness
so with those
so a few pieces of advice I'd like to
continue on that on the gratitude and
say thank you thank you to my advisor
thank you to this University for giving
me a helping hand there you go
and thank you to my family and all the
friends that I've had along the way
thank you for their love I appreciate it
[Applause]